you're the next Jurassic world movie yes
sir fallen kingdom come on Kingdom and
this is a high honor
Funko has put out two figures of you as
dr. Ian Malcolm these are Funko or funko
funkopop Funko pop I think Funko yeah
it's Funko right what did I say that you
said I say funko funkopop Oh what what's
the difference what's what's your Co I
think you were like like a fun company
the fun company funko funkopop oh I lost
my tail I've lost my tail they can put
they can put a man on the moon but they
cannot attach these things so that I'm
not Jackie Chan I'm not I'm not I
haven't been I've been running around
here it's falling out yeah put it in my
pocket that catch a falling star and put
it in my pocket never let me go
I always got a tune up my sleeve - what
are you looking for I want to call the
police these your Funko dolls these are
look at these these are tough to look at
this yeah that's pretty sexy right there
it's meant to depict my scene from
Jurassic the one though with the first
one when I you know just Rove so we now
would you like to rub your own dog's
nipple you can be my nipple my own dog
your dog you said duh oh you were
rubbing your dog earlier in a story I
don't this whole thing I don't think any
of this is arable ladies right now
there's no one like huh their minds
going to do something i oughtn't ya
you